ya vimos cómo hacer una titulación ha
sido base ahora veamos una titulación
redox digamos que tenemos una solución
que contiene cationes de hierro dos más
y no sabemos la concentración pero la
podemos conocer a través de una
titulación redox digamos que tenemos 10
mililitros de nuestra solución ácida
como por ejemplo de ácido sulfúrico en
la que tenemos cationes de hierro 2 más
una fuente de protones provenientes del
ácido y a esta solución le agregamos un
poco de permanganato de potasio aquí
tenemos un poco de permanganato de
potasio k mn4 y supongamos que su
concentración es 0.02 molar
ahora el permanganato de potasio es una
fuente de iones permanganato porque
tenemos acá más y mn
4 - así que también tenemos una fuente
de neones permanganato entonces dejamos
caer algunas gotas de permanganato de
potasio y ocurre una reacción redox esta
es nuestra ecuación balanceada si no
están muy seguros de cómo balancear una
reacción redox los invito a que vean el
vídeo sobre reacciones redox en medio
ácido echemos un vistazo rápidamente a
los estados de oxidación en el oxígeno
tenemos menos 2 y como tenemos 4
oxígenos menos 2 x 4 es igual a menos 8
así que para el manganeso debemos tener
más 7 porque más 7 y menos 8 es igual a
menos 1 entonces el manganeso tiene
un estado de oxidación de 7 ahora del
lado de nuestros productos
tenemos m n 2 más el estado de oxidación
es más 2 así que el manganeso pasa de un
estado de oxidación de más 7 a más 2
eso significa que sufre una reducción en
su estado de oxidación por lo tanto el
manganeso es reducido ahora vamos con el
hierro aquí tenemos hierro dos más como
reactivo así que su estado de oxidación
es más 2 y en nuestros productos
obtenemos hierro 3 más tiene un estado
de oxidación de más 3 entonces como el
hierro pasa de más 2 a más 3 hay un
aumento en el estado de oxidación eso
significa que el hierro 2 más es oxidado
entonces si dejamos caer algunas gotas
de permanganato de potasio ésta
formando estos productos y estos iones
no presentan color en la solución son
transparentes así que conforme el
permanganato reacciona el color violeta
desaparece y persiste la solución
transparente pero supongamos que ya
agregamos un cierto volumen de
permanganato y la solución es
transparente pero si agregamos una gota
en exceso provocamos que toda la
solución cambie a violeta la solución
era transparente pero al agregar una
gota extra de permanganato la solución
cambia a color violeta esto indica el
punto final de la titulación porque como
ya dijimos todos nuestros productos son
transparentes no tienen color y si
obtenemos una solución violeta al final
eso significa que tenemos un pequeño
exceso de iones permanganato sin
reaccionar y que ya reaccionó todo
el hierro 2 más que teníamos presente al
inicio entonces ahí detenemos nuestra
titulación y observamos que gastamos un
cierto volumen de la solución de
permanganato de potasio digamos que
terminamos aquí y si empezamos
aproximadamente por acá podemos ver que
usamos este volumen de la solución
supongamos que fue de 20 mililitros
usamos 20 mililitros de la solución de
permanganato de potasio para titular
completamente al hierro 2 más ahora
nuestro objetivo es encontrar la
concentración de hierro 2 más pero para
eso primero calculemos cuántos moles de
permanganato fueron necesarios para
reaccionar completamente con el hierro 2
más podemos calcular los moles a partir
de la concentración molar y el volumen
sabemos que la polaridad es igual a
moles sobre litros
y la concentración de iones permanganato
es 0.02 0.02 queremos encontrar los
moles y el volumen que usamos en la
titulación fue de 20 mililitros que al
mover el punto decimal una dos tres
veces es igual a 0.02 litros
entonces 0.02 x 0.02 es igual a 0.00 04
usamos 0.000 4 moles de permanganato
para que reaccionara todo el hierro 2
más que teníamos en la solución inicial
ahora necesitamos calcular cuántos moles
de hierro 2 más teníamos al inicio para
eso usemos nuestra reacción redux en el
permanganato tenemos un coeficiente de 1
y en el hierro 2 más
5 así que podemos hacer una relación
molar entre el permanganato y el hierro
2 más por cada molde permanganato
tenemos 5 de hierro entonces cuántos
moles de permanganato usamos para que
reaccionaran con el hierro 2 más bueno
ya dijimos que 0.000 4
tenemos 0.000 4 moles de permanganato y
x son los moles de hierro 2 más que
teníamos al inicio así que simplemente
multiplicamos 5 por 0.000 4 y eso es
igual a 0.00 2x es igual a 0.00 dos
moles de hierro 2 más
muy bien finalmente para calcular la
concentración de los cationes de hierro
2 más como ya tenemos los moles y
conocemos el volumen original que era de
10 mililitros la concentración de hierro
2 más es igual a 0.00 2 moles 0.002
moles de hierro 2 más entre el volumen
inicial que fue de 10 mililitros 0.01
litros
entonces 0.002 entre 0.01 es igual a 0.2
nuestra concentración inicial de hierro
dos más en solución fue 0.2 molar
también podríamos haber usado la
ecuación mv es igual a emv y
modificarlas porque la relación molar no
es 1 a 1 pero yo prefiero hacer todos
estos cálculos para saber exactamente
qué está pasando